it is the one-year anniversary of the
January 6th Trump riots we are going to
have a little bit of coverage of that
later today we're also going to carry on
tomorrow's show we'll have some clips
from Joe Biden's uh statement his speech
today about that one year anniversary
very very heavily placing a lot of the
blame on Donald Trump did Joe Biden
today uh but we'll talk about that later
and tomorrow there's so much else to get
to and I'm going to jump right into it
as many of you know any opportunity that
I have to clear up confusion or
misinformation disinformation propaganda
or bad math and statistics those are
opportunities that I relish and
unfortunately the opportunity we have
today is to look at a clip from
Republican senator Rand Paul who to some
people very convincingly made an
argument yesterday
not only against vaccine mandates but
against vaccines at all when it comes to
coronavirus and so we're going to look
at this clip there's a bunch of
different concepts here that are
relevant and that are important so I'm
going to be making notes of each of the
aspects of what he says that need to be
discussed see if you can pick out the
fallacious claims and then we're going
to talk about it in more detail let's
take a look and so what we're dealing
with is now a different disease and it
needs to be treated differently we need
to get rid of a hysteria but the people
who are promoting this stereo work for
the government I mean this is Dr fauci's
fault largely worse because he's still
hysterically talking about mandates and
shutting people down and not letting
people fly and blaming the unvaccinated
everybody's getting this vaccinated
unvaccinated in fact the majority of the
people in the hospital now are
vaccinated because almost everybody's
been vaccinated
now that is a lot of disinformation but
there's one really funny thing
at the end of what Rand Paul says he
actually gets to something that's really
important in understanding the
effectiveness and efficacy of vaccines
which is he says because almost everyone
is vaccinated now that's not actually
true in the United States we have a
pathetically embarrassingly low
vaccination rate relative to so many
other countries specifically because of
Republicans and Trump supporters who
have one of the lowest vaccination rates
in any country that has widespread
access to vaccines you can look at
countries that don't yet have widespread
access to vaccines and say well they
have lower rates than Republicans yes
but they have no access to vaccines
among groups so if you look at you know
uh Spanish right Wingers and you know
whatever group you want American
Republicans are arguably and I think
probably undoubtedly although uh right
up there the least uh vaccinated group
among any group in countries with
widespread vaccine access and by far the
most unvaccinated group in the United
States but Rand Paul gets to something
really important
in a country where everyone is
vaccinated
everybody with covid would be vaccinated
that doesn't really tell you anything
about how good the vaccines are at
preventing illness at all
preventing symptomatic illness
preventing serious illness
hospitalization or death I mean think
about that no vaccine is 100 percent and
thus the more vaccinated a country is
the higher number of people who are
vaccinated that are going to get that
disease it doesn't actually tell you how
much better off you are being vaccinated
than not
if you get to 100 vaccinated every case
will be in a vaccinated person what we
need to be looking at are the outcomes
and the relative risk imagine a country
with 99 vaccination
and 90 of the hospitalizations are in
that one percent that's not vaccinated
even though uh uh you you have this high
level of vaccination you would still say
you're way better off vaccinated than
unvaccinated so let's look at some data
along those lines
um when we look at
um we can look at a bunch of different
places let's start with Kentucky you
look at hospitalizations in Kentucky as
of yesterday okay
45 inpatient hospitalizations
76 percent were unvaccinated whereas 24
were vaccinated even though the majority
of Kentucky residents are vaccinated
three quarters of those in the hospital
did not have the vaccine the relative
risk of being unvaccinated is
significant okay you look at critical
care and ICU patients 11 of them
100 of them are unvaccinated
so even though Rand Paul might look and
say most people are vaccinated and the
numbers are going crazy look at the 11
people in an ICU I think this is
admitted yesterday 100 of them are
unvaccinated and if you look at the six
patients that are on ventilators none of
those people are vaccinated this is what
we're hearing anecdotally from emergency
room doctors the people with three
vaccines are having very mild illness
and don't need to be in the hospital
generally speaking there's obviously
exceptions to everything let's look next
at whoa that's a picture of me don't
know where that came from let's look at
Ontario in Ontario you have three charts
here I'll describe them for people that
are not um that are not watching that
are just listening today if you look at
cases cases are going up among everybody
now these These are per capita so this
is important to understand this is per
capita the leftmost graph coveted cases
you see that the rate among the
unvaccinated is significantly higher
than among those with at least two doses
it's going up for everybody because
Omicron is so contagious now look at
who's in the hospital the gap between
unvaccinated and vaccinated in the
hospital is incredible in Ontario among
the unvaccinated the hospitalization
rate is about 550 per million
inhabitants whereas the rate among the
vaccinated is only about a hundred you
have a five and a half times higher rate
of being in the hospital if you're
unvaccinated and then if you look at ICU
the numbers are even more stunning
um ICU occupancy among unvaccinated
people is about 140 per million
it's only about 10 for those who are
vaccinated so that puts you
14 times higher risk of ending up in the
ICU if you are not vaccinated last
illustration here is from New York City
looking at New York City here uh you see
this is just cases cases are going up
for everybody but the purple line is
cases per hundred thousand among the
unvaccinated it's about 5500 per hundred
thousand cases among the vaccinated are
about 300 okay
15x or so higher so Rand Paul is
mathematically correct in that
increasingly as more people get
vaccinated more and more of the cases
will be among the vaccinated that's just
simple math
base rates but the rate of
hospitalization
um intubation and death continues to be
dramatically higher among those who have
not been vaccinated this it's this this
is why this is around the world there's
no country in which this is not being
observed so very dangerous
disinformation from Rand Paul which a
lot of these Fox News viewer sycophant
types grasp onto for dear life and
uncritically repeat uh understand the
math very very important it is the one
year anniversary of the Donald Trump
January 6th riots in Washington D.C
tomorrow we'll talk about Joe Biden's
speech on in which he very heavily very
strongly blames Donald Trump for what
happened a year ago uh if you can
imagine a more
brain dead
ill-conceived dangerous action than this
Donald Trump last night on the eve of
the anniversary of the Trump riots put
out a statement calling for Maga Nation
to quote rise up
think about what they did last year
and think about the insanity of putting
out such a statement once again let's
take a look at uh the Donald Trump
statement that he put out yesterday uh
let's see if we can get zoomed in on
this so we can really take take a close
look at it statement by Donald J Trump
put out yesterday the Biden
administration's response to covid is
getting worse every day Joe Biden said
quote there is no federal solution to
the pandemic but he then federalized the
distribution of antibodies and red
states are getting the short end of the
stick that's been widely debunked by the
way
although I agree that it was a really
bad idea for Joe Biden to run on fixing
covet and then say there's no federal
solution then why'd you run on it that
was a that was a mistake by Joe Biden in
my Administration we respected the role
of Governors to take care of their own
States and they could request antibodies
and Therapeutics depending on what they
needed that's the way our Capital C
country is supposed to run now there's
talk by the Biden Administration again
about closing schools and even vaccine
mandates for school children remember
this stuff is really determined at the
state level
so the fact that it's being discussed as
whether it makes sense is very very
different than taking power away from
Governors okay this is an outrage and
here's the key line and Maga Nation
should rise up and oppose this egregious
federal government overreach this is now
you might see this and say David to
normal people that wouldn't move them to
violence we are not dealing with normal
people
we're dealing with people here in
trumpists who last year committed
hundreds of crimes because Donald Trump
said let's go to the Capitol these are
people who have spent the last year
terrorizing school board meetings and
places where localities local
municipalities not the federal
government local officials are
discussing masking vaccination remote
learning all these different things and
now Donald Trump says to these people
you should rise up rise up and oppose
egregious federal government overreach
this is the exact type of weaponization
of ignorance and radicalism that leads
to real world violence and Trump is
doing it again on the eve of the January
6 riots going on to say the Democrats
are so incredibly mandate happy and
there is a discussion about a vaccine
mandate for school kids this year in
Detroit and other democrat-runplaces our
Administration did what they said could
not be done vaccines in record time
remember that had nothing to do with
Trump based on technology under
development for decades but we never
issued mandates and I never would people
should be able to choose how they want
to govern their own health the federal
government must be reined in and give
people freedom to decide whether they
want to be vaccinated or not
Joe Biden said he would never issue
mandates but he did it anyway like so
many other things so of course that's
pretty dishonest in the sense that
there's a there's you know Joe Biden is
not issued just a government mandate
that people must be vaccinated he has
done things in terms of employment he
has done things in terms of the
Department of Transportation Etc you can
say it's good or bad you can say it's
moral or immoral it is not illegal and
it is not something Joe Biden said he
wouldn't do we can debate the
effectiveness of it but it is a lie to
frame it in this way so on the eve of
the January 6th Riot anniversary
Donald Trump is doing exactly what he
did 364 days prior which is to tell lies
about a thought supposedly authoritarian
Democrats and encourage his followers to
rise up to go there and he's talking
about rising up against the federal
government that is the exact same thing
that they did on January 6 2021 I'm
hopeful that because
I mean listen a lot of these trumpists
now have seen more than 700 people
charged for their role last year in the
riots because there's a heavy police
presence in Washington D.C My Hope Is
there will be no repeat although some of
them would love to do it my hope is
there will be no repeat this year uh and
so far as of today that seems to be the
case I want to remind everybody Tuesday
we will be doing the first David Pacman
show viewer chess tournament of 2022
Tuesday January 11 6 PM Eastern uh all
you have to do for now is join the David
packman show chess club at
davidpackman.com chess you'll need a
chess.com account it's free I'm not
selling you anything other than a good
time we've got some great uh chess
streamers who are going to be
participating a grand master Benjamin
Feingold will be playing uh
International Master Eric Rosen is going
to be joining us in streaming uh women's
fide Master Anna cramlin kremling is
going to be participating in streaming
so it's going to be fun for everybody
you'll be matched up against people of
your level my level is very low but it's
still a really really good time so just
join the club free at davidpackman.com
chess and then we'll have more
information next week
remember that the David pakman show is a
dependent on folks who decide to get
memberships on my website you can sign
up at joinpakman.com we do an extra show
every day for our members we also offer
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show for our members and when we
do viewer Town Halls like we did a few
weeks ago members get a separate
priority line to talk to me uh and lots
of other great little perks so sign up
at joinpakman.com you can use the new
coupon code
wow22 to get a significant discount at
joinpakman.com let's look at some
interesting posts from this morning on
the David Pacman show subreddit the
David Pacman show subreddit can be found
at davidpackman.com
r-e-d-d-i-t more than 33
000 of our viewers and listeners have
subscribed there uh first post is
concerns over right-wing friend this is
an interesting topic user Atman writes
hey everyone as the title implies I have
a bit of a serious issue growing up I
had a conservative phase I was only like
16 and was pulled in by the 2016 wave of
conservatism on YouTube and social media
I ended up making some friends at this
time with similar interests we were
pretty much your standard I'm a
classical liberal type watched Ben
Shapiro debates maybe some Paul Joseph
Watson a lot of Stephen Crowder over
time I drifted away and became a lot
more liberal these friends however did
the opposite they're extremely right
wing they think covet is a left-wing
power grab which is annoying uh
considering I've worked on a covid unit
since April and see it firsthand Trump
actually won the election armed
Insurrection is Justified and I fear
they're even beginning to dabble in
white nationalism our talks have become
noticeably more tense all they do is
post guns on their Instagrams and spam
their stories with far-right propaganda
is there any hope of helping them
should I just cut them off if I was able
to drift liberal could I manage to help
them as well I appreciate the advice I
mean listen this is a really I get calls
like this all the time from people this
is a really personal thing I don't think
there's any issue with having friends
with diverse political opinions I have
friends with diverse political opinions
that include you know kind of casual
center-right Republicans mostly focused
on tax and regulation issues people who
are sort of outside of the traditional
political space but are just culturally
very liberal or conservative but I don't
have any friends that are outrageous
Mega lunatics and white nationalists and
all these different things because that
is so at odds with what I believe those
views often Rife with anti-Semitism and
xenophobia and all these things there's
no way for me to put that aside and just
talk about yesterday's basketball game
there's a sort of line and that line is
different for everybody the question
about bringing them to the left that's a
different question question all together
and it really comes down to how much
work are you willing to put in when we
talk about deprogramming and
de-radicalizing people we're talking
about something that can take months of
concerted effort if not longer as I've
said before I think the most
kind of least the least confrontational
way to approach this is to just
regularly ask
basic probing questions about how did
you come to believe that how did you
come to believe that kind of a soft
Socratic method of questioning but it's
a very personal thing what you are
willing to sort of endure in terms of
getting to that point of having a shot
at disabusing them of these beliefs but
let us know how it goes another post I
spotted user Philo posted an article
about turning point USA
building the next generation of
conservative influencers influencer
first conservative second I have talked
for years about how the right is willing
to lose money on individual projects
like throwing tons of cash at these in
these organizations that program young
right-wingers to go out and spread the
message so to speak because they see it
as a bigger investment in the longer
term
the right has a lot of views including
on abortion gay marriage taxes Health
Care where if you just ask questions in
an unbiased way you see that the country
continues to move to the left to the
left to the left but what is the right
doing to continue winning elections and
controlling the narrative they are just
dumping cash into training up advocates
for their perspectives right out of
college and we on the left should be
very worried about it
I have conversations all the time with
wealthy-ish and very wealthy center-left
people and actual progressives as well
and they say how can I deploy my
resources and I say you know if you
really want to make a difference you've
got to fund left-wing media and create
organizations equivalent to what the
right has to get people to become
Advocates when they come out of college
because the right has the ground game
figured out and they'll sometimes say
well what about George Soros you know
often is what's mentioned Soros is
operating on a very different level
Soros is not doing what the right is
doing with groups like Turning Point USA
and others so without a doubt if the
left really wants to control that space
and actually work to make the country's
uh sort of sort of public political
orientation match that of what people
are privately saying are their views
because remember our elected officials
are way to the right of where the
country is we've got to fight them the
way that they fight which is dumping a
ton of cash into these organizations
Turning Point USA it's a vile
organization but they they are doing
exactly what the left fails to do last
post was and I got a ton of these
anybody know what's up with the
subscriber feed on the website
I thought David was on vacation and I
wasn't paying attention but there's
there are new segments on YouTube and
I'm not finding the content on the
website it is 2022 so you must a message
to all members with peace and love you
have to go to member content 2022.
to find this year's shows 2021 is over I
know a lot of people miss this but the
content is there we are back join the
discussion at davidpackman.com Reddit
we've been covering the growing Civil
War so to speak between the anti-trump
and pro-trump Republican party but the
anti-trump so-called anti-trump
Republican party is often people who
were never into Trump we are now seeing
something different as a result of
Donald Trump making really mild milk
toast uncontroversial statements about
the vaccines are pretty good at keeping
you out of the hospital for covet a
bunch of actual former trumpists have
turned on Donald Trump and some are even
burning Maga hats I'm gonna play a clip
for you here a former Arizona Republican
Senate candidate uh what was this guy's
name I don't even remember this guy's
name uh Daniel McCarthy uh yes Daniel
McCarthy he has completely turned on
Donald Trump is challenging Trump to a
debate at the Trump rally scheduled for
next Saturday calls Trump quote a little
[ __ ] and then uses a flamethrower to
burn his own Mega hat this is great this
is great and I'll tell you why in a
moment let's take a look at the video
Let's listen
hey Donald Trump this is Daniel McCarthy
in Arizona the world is waking up to
your massive grift please stop with the
smoke and mirrors with these audits stop
with your fundraising stop a
establishment candidate endorsements
stop pushing this gene therapy no I have
to stop there
YouTube has a policy where
it's not enough that my audience knows
I support and accept the science on
vaccines every time such statements are
made like the vaccines or Gene therapies
I have to rebut it every time to be in
compliance with YouTube this is what's
going on so I want to remind you guys we
have extensively debunked the notion
that the vaccines are quote Gene
therapies they are Gene based vaccines
but they are not Gene therapies that
change your genes okay I just have to
it's important I have to do that every
time I'm sorry sauce I hear you're
coming to Florence Arizona for another
one of your do-nothing raw raw session
rallies well I have an offer for you I
will give one million dollars to the
charity of your choice wow if you take
30 minutes of your stage time on January
15th and debate me or answer my
questions even in front of your crowd
think about all the things that you've
done that you've got you've not been
held accountable for you ushered in
medical tyranny that's not true Donald
Trump did not usher in any medical
tyranny you exploded our national debt
that's true he did explode the national
debt you relinquished our sovereignty
with the usmca trade deal that's untrue
usmca very similar to NAFTA quite
uncontroversial certainly did not give
up any sovereignty
as an Obama did with fixed Knicks that I
don't even know about I'm not even sure
about that one you warned about election
from Rod but yet you did nothing to
prevent it even after my team months in
advance warned you after we were stolen
from in the Senate primary that's just
crazy talk that one's hard that one's
there's so many elements to that when
it's hard to even refute you gave up on
Therapeutics and you push an
experimental gene therapy and again the
vaccine is not an experimental gene
therapy people are dying because of
their trust in you now
that's interesting people are dying
because of their trust in you there are
people dying because they believed based
on Trump that they shouldn't get the
vaccine that's not actually what Trump
said it's true people are dying because
of their trust in Trump but not for the
reason that McCarthy is saying that
that's kind of a complicated one
connected the lockdowns and you
surrounded yourself with swamp creatures
for four years he did surround himself
with swamp creatures Trump did not enact
any lockdowns the January 6th protesters
that came down to the Capitol you set
them up those people are being treated
worse than dogs now they so setup
suggests it was I mean Trump just
encouraged them to do what they did it
wasn't really a setup and these are your
most loyal supporters Trump you failed
America yes you're the most deceptive
president in American history that's
true that's true trust me there's been a
lot of psyops before I've posted the
terms and conditions of my one million
dollar offer to my website
www.demandaniel.com I look forward to
seeing you you on January 15th although
I know you won't do it because you're a
little [ __ ] right
and so now he's getting out of the truck
and he's gonna flamethrow his own uh
Maga hat so the magats are revolting
and there it is
well
and then he Stomps it out
and then he drives over it with his
truck
yeah
well Trump will never talk to me because
he knows he can't because his family's
name would be tarnished forever
okay so obviously this guy's completely
out of his mind I mean completely cuckoo
for Cocoa Puffs but the fact that now
even trumpists are turning on Trump is
very interesting tomorrow we are going
to have a report about Stephanie Grisham
very briefly the press secretary for
Trump
um she says there's a group of 15
Republicans getting together to try to
preemptively neuter Trump from ever
running in 2024 so there's a very
interesting counter Trump movement even
within trumpism we're going to talk
about it you can see the clip if you
were listening to this segment you can
see the clip of this Daniel McCarthy guy
flame throwing the Maga hat on our
Instagram which is David Pacman show on
Instagram you can also find me on
Instagram at david.pakman
it's great to Welcome to the program
today Jeffrey Kane senior fellow in
critical emerging Technologies at the
Lincoln policy Network and also author
of the book The Perfect police state an
undercover Odyssey into China's
terrifying surveillance dystopia of the
future a book I recently read uh great
to have you on today I really appreciate
it thanks for having me David so I for
people who maybe have not studied this
topic or have only a kind of passing or
a rudimentary understanding of what has
been going on in China in particular
with the with the uyghur population
maybe we can back up a little and ask
the question what have relations been
between the Chinese Communist party and
the uyghur population particularly in
xinjiang historically in China
um yes so uh so xinjiang is a region of
China that's about twice the size of
Texas and it's on you could say the
Western frontier of what is today China
but historically it was home to a group
of people called the uyghurs
um who are mostly Muslim and they
populated this region for you know for
hundreds you know almost a thousand
years uh this is the this is really
their Homeland uh I think a good
comparison would be to imagine uh you
know the the European settlers in
America and the Native Americans and
that's sort of how China looks at this
region it's a place that it's been
expanding Westward into and it keeps
running into this uyghur population and
these other ethnic minority groups who
practice a different religion have a
distinct language uh distinct culture
there are about 12 million people there
sparsely populated area it's it's Oasis
and desert and mountains and it truly is
the place that China has been and trying
to build and develop with oil and
railroads and you know turning it into
this Frontier land where Chinese
settlers can can go and they can find
their riches and opportunity so in I
mean in terms of the motivations for for
the treatment of the uyghur population
to be what it is there are you know
perspectives that say this is mostly
xenophobic lines based on Muslim
religion there are other perspectives
that say there's a sort of business
oriented perspective as you're talking
about and desires to to turn that area
into something that is much more
financially viable what is the origin of
the circumstances as we now see them
so uh there's a lot of Origins to the
situation in xinjiang there are
currently about 1.8 million people in
concentration camps in this region which
is about one-tenth of the minority
population so you know imagine the uh
you know the the North American
equivalent it's as if you know a
minority blacks or or Native Americans
or whoever it might be uh one tenth of
them being taken away without being
charged with a crime to a concentration
camp the reasons for this uh many
reasons uh but it mostly goes back to
you could say a war on terror just takes
to an extreme uh you know the the US was
waging the war on terror for many years
it's calmed down now but China seized on
that war on terror and took it to a
it's authoritarian system over these
people
uh you know that the practice states
that they're affected terrorist ideas
that they need to be purged and so they
created this total surveillance dystopia
using artificial intelligence and
overhanded policing and facial
recognition cameras everywhere to to try
to get inside the thoughts of every
single week or to predict their behavior
and to try to turn them into good
Patriots of the state
okay so you mentioned the facial
recognition in the book you talk about a
lot of the different sort of elements of
the surveillance state that that are in
place there kind of a two-part question
can you talk about some of the other
surveillance methods that that are used
and also are these only in place in this
region or are these also to some degree
in other parts of China as well
so when I was writing the book it was
starting in xinjiang these measures were
being rolled out in the region and they
were experimental about four years when
I started writing the book since I've
published it these methods these tactics
and technologies have expanded uh
throughout many parts of China so Tibet
great great example inner Mongolia there
are all these regions of China that are
home to minorities that are who are
being repressed violently so to give you
an idea of other tactics just imagine an
old sci-fi novel or a movie I think that
this is most like the movie Minority
Report with Tom Cruise about a police
force that tries to engage in predictive
policing they can try to predict a
murder and then arrest the person and
brainwash them they brainwash them in
this system before the murder can happen
that's what's happening
you know whether a person leaves the
home the front door at 9am every day to
go to work whether they go grocery
shopping you know uh every other day at
6 PM what do they buy there are cameras
watching them what do they read in the
case of my book I found one young woman
in too many books and there is a uh you
know there are these camera systems
everywhere that are watching you and
gathering this data and then trying to
predict are you going to be a threat to
the state in the future are you going to
try and commit some kind of terrorist
rebellious act against the Communist
party and so they take you to a
concentration camp psychologically
physically torture you and try to get
you to resent your supposed evil ways
and to become this this shell of your
former itself where you simply accept
and internalize the demands of the
Communist party now in the book you you
describe kind of two different layers
there's the re-education camps and what
are sometimes called the concentration
camps and the concentration camps are
worse than the re-education camps it
seems that typically there's more of an
exit path from the re-education camps if
you sort of comply and or you know do it
doing what you're asked it can you talk
about the relationship between these two
kind of levels that exist there there
certainly so there are more levels now
the system has expanded since I wrote
the book
um so the lowest level is just it I mean
it they call it a re-education center
um the formal name is re-education and
Training Center and this is a place
where you'll be summoned there as a
uyghur person uh to undergo you know
patriotic lessons to study law and
Civics and all that sort of thing and
then after you you know show you might
go for like two years for a class and
you can go home every day maybe at 6 pm
to see your family or maybe go home for
the weekends but you have to stay there
a certain amount of time
um that's the that's one of the lower
levels uh if you're deemed a more
serious threat then you're kicked up to
what is called a detention center and a
Detention Center is just a euphemism for
a full fully loaded concentration camp
that's where they have the guard dogs
and the SWAT teams and the uh the guard
posts and you know snipers up there
watching everyone these places are truly
terrifying I haven't been able to
personally visit one and obviously it
wouldn't be you know something you can
just drop in and you know report on
gather information on but I was able to
gather I interviewed more than 100
uyghurs who had been through these camps
who had managed to get out you know
through various means uh and just the
stories they told were absolutely
terrifying I mean this is
um this is something different
altogether from the atrocities that we
saw in the 20th century the 20th century
was the age of genocide it was the age
of the uh you know the the big camps
where they had Mass Graves of Auschwitz
of the Kumar Rouge in Cambodia um you
know the the mass the mass killings of
of men women and children
um you know that that was truly a
terrifying time to be alive in a lot of
places uh when it comes to xinjiang and
China in you know in the 21st century
and in the year 2022 now we're seeing
being the evolution of new forms of mass
surveillance and mass atrocities the the
Chinese Nation the government has
perfected ways of controlling people of
finding ways to control their identity
to try to brainwash them into being
someone else without actually outright
you know killing them they don't pull
out a gun and shoot you and put you in a
mass grave they don't have a gas chamber
they they manage to erase your identity
erase your culture and to essentially
commit genocide through that through the
use of overhanded Technology
so there is a movement that
oh man it's like hard to even know how
to do this Justice in bringing it up
there are some who are increasingly
denying
to different degrees that this is even
taking place now there are some who say
it's it's not a genocide they don't
necessarily deny some element of what
you're saying but you're saying people
aren't really being wholesale killed
that part's not going on although what's
going on isn't good there's others who
are making claims like The Messengers
presumably some of the people you spoke
to
are people who are making up these
stories to either attack the Chinese
Communist party because they are
anti-anti-communist or whatever I don't
want to re too narrowly characterize
where this comes from but in the U.S it
does seem to be folks who generally
speaking are more sympathetic to not
only the Chinese Communist party but to
the politics of the Hugo Chavez Maduro
type regimes in Venezuela there seems to
be sort of like a a in being in League
there
I can't adjudicate every single claim
but can you talk a little bit about the
origins of this and whether there's any
aspect of it that require we should be
paying attention to specifically
uh yeah so uh we know uh without any
doubt whatsoever by now that these
atrocities are happening that the camps
exist we have a full documentation we
have satellite imagery
um we have thousands upon thousands of
testimony from refugees many of which
line up in my case I interviewed 168
people including not just refugees but
people who were inside the system who
actually worked for the Chinese
technology companies building these
systems uh you know I I mean we went
through Chinese corporate records even
Chinese companies that build these
systems they like to brag they're proud
of what they do they don't see it as
something shameful or worth hiding you
know they've admitted to it openly in
the Chinese language if you can read
Mandarin you can find corporate reports
that talk about what they're doing in
xinjiang there isn't you know there
there are no secrets anymore to what's
going on and it's really unfortunate
that you know in the states in
particular or just in the western world
uh you know there are people um they
tend to be more on the left on the hard
left who um you know they they think
that um you have to choose the the
reasoning goes that you have to choose
one or the other if you side with the
United States of America then you are an
imperialist colonialist uh bastard who's
just trying to oppress China trying to
oppress you know Global non-aligned uh
you know people of color movements
that's sort of how they frame it so
therefore the idea you should be
sympathetic to China and see these you
know these accusations of genocide these
camps therefore they must be made up by
this you know this American imperialist
System these evil conservatives are just
making up stuff to smear China to
justify a war against China uh you know
that's it's just um you know it's
outright the nihilism and it's really
unfortunate that some of the these these
sort of these leftists these hard
leftists and socialists
um who claim to uphold Progressive value
use you know at home they talk about
social justice and then when it comes to
you know minorities overseas in other
countries they're on the side of an
authoritarian regime so the term Tanki
and it just so I don't know if you've
heard that turn pinky but yeah I've said
before I because it has such a
pejorative uh connotation I tend to call
it the Revolutionary left and this is
someone on the left who considers myself
a progressive I've chosen that term but
certainly tanki's a term I'm familiar
with
yeah yeah and um you know I would
consider myself kind of a progressive
Centrist you know I support human rights
around the world you know there are also
people on the other side too on the
right who uh you know just have these
crazy crazy views about uh you know the
Chinese Global conspiracy taking over
the world so um you know it's uh it's
unfortunate that this particular topic
gets polarized uh when there are major
human rights atrocities uh happening
what about more specific so that's that
gives us a great kind of General
orientation what about the more narrow
claim that a lot of what is being
described is absolutely happening you
can't deny the surveillance uh the
satellite surveillance all that but that
there is not genocide taking place
so the genocide question is uh step
question uh and that falls under the
international law of of uh genocide
um so so
so here's the thing about the genocide
uh question
the one of the major problems that needs
to be one of the things that needs to be
established is the intents to commit
genocide Chinese officials defend
themselves by arguing
um that they are not committing genocide
they are simply developing the region
they're they claim that they're trying
to lessen birth rates they don't want
you know they want Family Planning and
when they defend themselves that way
that places these projects in a
different kind of framework and that's
what makes it more difficult to prove
that this is actually a genocide now
under international law the one major
factor that would make this a genocide
that numerous academics and Scholars
have documented well is the forced
sterilization of women the force
sterilization uh in an attempt to erase
an entire people to erase the Next
Generation it's uh and that is really
you know I think that if there's going
to be that one uh you know kind of that
one Turning Point within international
law that one thing
um that's going to be the thing that
will Define this as genocide in the
future
uh the book is the perfect police state
we've been speaking with the author
Jeffrey Kane I so appreciate your time
today and and really uh recommend the
book to to anybody who's interested in
this topic or isn't yet interested but
but really should be uh really
appreciate your time thanks David
foreign I was not initially going to do
this story so many of you wrote to me
about it that I I'm going to do it but I
want to again mention that there's a lot
going on right now with Ron DeSantis his
wife is is in cancer treatment and I
just want to be careful with with this
story
um the back story on this is that Ron
DeSantis the Republican Florida governor
who maybe mismanaged covid more than any
other governor in the country at least
up there in the top five basically went
missing publicly for two weeks uh on
December 17th a bagel place in Ocala
Florida posted a picture of DeSantis
being there DeSantis was then missing
from the public for 13 days on December
30th posted a picture from that same
bagel place the same picture saying go
get bagels but at that point we knew
that picture was almost two weeks old so
it didn't really allay concerns about
where is he and the speculation was did
he have covid and he had to go out of
the public eye for some period of time
because he didn't want to publicly admit
that he had coveted it was speculative
without a doubt then it was stated no no
no no Ron DeSantis was busy going to his
wife's cancer treatment completely
legitimate except the statement was that
that was only on December 29th it
doesn't really explain his 12 days of
absence dating Back to December 17th on
New Year's Eve DeSantis surfaced at a
big concert with his wife who again is
immunocompromised she's undergoing
cancer treatment no masks very very
dangerous thing to do and the
speculation continued to be was DeSantis
hiding covid for that period of time a
video has now been released from
yesterday
in which Rhonda sandis something is very
wrong with Ron DeSantis his voice is
quivering he's out of breath he's
struggling to breathe kind of like Trump
when Trump remember when Trump left the
hospital with covet and he defiantly
took off his mask and then you could see
Trump really really struggling to
breathe it's a similar thing with
DeSantis but at the same time he kind of
seems almost in tears and maybe there
was a setback with his wife's treatment
so let's take a look at it and we I
don't know what's going on this could be
the additional evidence that he's been
hiding kovid could be that his wife had
a bad treatment day or a setback I don't
know but let's take a look and let's
take a listen by uh Dame Eagle who's our
Florida Deo secretary we also have
Chancellor Henry Mack from the Florida
Department of Education so this part is
more coveted like which is when you
speak speaking is more effort than
people might realize
and a lot of times with covid it's this
having to really labor each breath to
keep speaking so far later it seems more
like he's almost crying
Brad Ferguson senior VP and general
manager skywater Florida and Dale Miller
site director uh skywater Florida as
well as representative Fred Hawkins
Manufacturing
is something that we need and you can
hear that breath is you know you you the
the the multiple short breaths to try to
keep up with the oxygen he needs better
job of and uh we've worked really hard
in Florida to have
um more opportunities with vocational
education we have expanded our
manufacturing footprint of the State of
Florida and we want to continue to be
able to do that as we go forward so now
is where it starts shifting into it's
not just the trouble breathing he's he
starts to sound on the verge of tears
semiconductors are a huge issue if you
look at how the supply chain works we
are overly dependent
on foreign Nations including Taiwan
which is a good Ally of ours but which
is one that
excuse me which is one that is under
really serious pressure from the
Communist Party of China and so we have
an opportunity to do more here in the
United States and I think the more we
can do manufacturing assemiconductors
here the better off we'll be
so today I'm proud to be awarding six
million dollars to build infrastructure
that will connect Southern Osceola
County to the emerging neo-city
technology District this district is
already home to six companies including
skywater technology a U.S owned and
operated semiconductor Foundry well this
award will support nearly 5 400 jobs
Osceola County officials estimate that
this could lead to tens of thousands of
jobs once it's fully developed as
Osceola County continues to grow I'm
also awarding Valencia College with 3.7
million dollars to create new programs
that focus on Workforce training for
chip and semiconductor Industries
through this program students will be
able to be certified in operating
repairing and designing the robots that
are used to create semiconductors in
just 14 weeks Valencia estimates that in
the first two years 120 people will be
able to graduate and immediately find
work at the Neo City technology District
all right so listen I mean I want to be
careful with this his wife has cancer it
would be logical to be crying if her
treatment weren't going well but we
don't know what this is certainly you
know the back story he's missing two
weeks posts a picture that's two weeks
old to show that he's actually out there
says he was accompanying his wife to
cancer treatment but that apparently was
only on one day 12 days in and then
reappears using accessory muscles to
breathe and taking these short gasping
breaths and and just having a it's it's
all weird it's all really weird and it
reminds me of trump on the White House
balcony after taking off the mask and
breathing like that and we know why we
we know uh you know what the reason was
for Trump doing that so are are we ever
going to get the truth I don't know
is it reasonable to think that DeSantis
would hide covid if that's what he had
yes
absolutely I mean there's no doubt in my
mind and this was there was the idea of
hiding Trump's covet as well and it
became impossible it was just it's not
going to be possible once the facts
became known uh of how serious it was
once the reality sort of set in but
absolutely DeSantis would hide covet is
that what this is I don't really know as
we continue to follow the work of the
January 6th house investigation
committee uh special select committee it
is starting to reach further and further
and further into magaland and the news
now is that my pillow CEO Mike Lindell
says his phone records have been
subpoenaed by the house committee
it is now reaching pillow MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell says his phone records have
been subpoenaed by the house committee
investigating the January 6 riot at the
Capitol I wasn't there on January 6th
and yes they did subpoena my phone
records but we filed a complaint for
declaratory and injunctive relief
against the committee and Verizon to
completely invalidate this corrupt
subpoena Lindell said in a text message
to CNBC the Revelation came after CNBC
reported last month that Lindell has
spent 25 million dollars since Election
Day 2020 to push false claims of
election fraud we know that pillow was
at the White House in that very very
crazy period during which they were
trying to come up with any way to steal
this election from the guy who actually
won it Joe Biden and uh MyPillow CEO
Mike Lindell known to many of us
lovingly as Mike pillow or just pillow
is now embroiled in this investigation
meanwhile
pillow does seem to be losing confidence
that he's going to reinst get Donald
Trump reinstated you know all of 2020
and even uh 2020 I'm sorry the end of
2020 and all of 2021 he kept saying
Trump's going to be back by January
March April by Thanksgiving by the end
of the year he was asked just a couple
days ago by right-wing host Eric me
taxes I'm sorry my taxes my taxes
if Joe Biden will be out by the end of
2022 and pillow is not sounding as
confident anymore take a listen to this
I'm talking right now to our friend Mike
Lindell Mike
do you have confidence before we go into
these five things you mentioned one and
two do you believe that in this calendar
year of 2022 uh Biden will leave office
laugh
I you know that'd be subjective I would
I pray for that yeah now listen I'm
praying against it so the prayer cancels
out and I guess we'll have to go with
the courts or something like that this
is the least optimistic that pillow has
been and even in his interview with me
he was insisting it's all going to
happen it's all going to happen it's all
going to happen so a deflated mic pillow
here is Mike pillow also uh this uh just
a couple days ago saying his new thing
is trying to get different voting
locales
to change the voting machines that they
use on his recommendations like dude you
make pillows not voting machines oh
we're doing this and what we're doing we
have teams all these Grassroots they
will be approached by the way is that a
Minnesota accent Grassroots that is just
I I am I think I'm gonna adopt that I
like that they're they're County
Commissioners who make the decisions
whether to use the Minion or esns heart
they're all the same okay they also can
make the decision to not use the
machines remember all the machines are
defective everybody it's like an
effective it's like bad breaks on your
car I want to remind you because it's
important to stay in compliance on
YouTube it is not true that all voting
machines used in 2020 are defective
there is no evidence of that they don't
work for what they were intended to if
you're a county commissioner out there
right now you know what you can say bye
bye machines you know remember we the
public paid for those machines the
American people paid for those machines
and you know what we don't want him
anymore I don't care if you're a
Democrat or Republican you go to these
counties here because we're doing it and
saying hey um we we don't want these
machines we have a great replacement
it's 50 times cheaper whatever it is and
uh here's the technology and you know
what it works there yeah so there it is
now as crazy as it is to take voting
machine recommendations from a pillow
guy there are probably some County
Commissioners who will do it and so
we've got to be watching out for that we
have a voicemail number that number is
219 to David P here is a voicemail with
a different perspective on covid at this
point I don't know if this is serious or
a satire
so as we begin the third year of covert
I realized that covet can't be real this
is just the new version of The Truman
Show right and eventually we're going to
figure out it was all just a TV show
thanks you do a great job have a good
day I assume that it's a satire but uh
The Truman Show a fantastic film
starring Jim Carrey
um in which he doesn't know that he has
been raised in a television program and
uh the real world of population is
watching it and I mean listen
um I am open to the idea that we're
living in a simulation I don't know that
kovid is that proof I'll just leave it
at that we've got a great bonus show for
you today we will talk about Karl Rove
saying hey these Republicans they gotta
just go hard against the Trump rioters
this is not something you want to mess
around with we will talk about the
ethical and legal questions surrounding
Sean Hannity and his text messages
related to the Trump riots and we will
talk about you know I know it's 2022.
Maricopa County Arizona officials are
finally ready to say the 2020 election
is over they seem ready to say we're
we're not going to get Arizona flipped
from Joe Biden to Donald Trump they're
accepting it now in January of 2022. all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show sign up at joinpakman.com